this is the Boeing factory near Seattle
where they make the 737 max planes
journalists invited inside for the first
time since they were grounded following
two deadly crashes as Boeing announces
updates to make the aircraft safer we're
going to do everything that we can do to
ensure that accidents like these never
happen again we're working with
customers and regulators to restore
faith in our industry and also to
reaffirm our commitment to safety and to
earning the trust of the flying public
the two incidents more recently with
Ethiopian Airlines and before that with
Lyon air in Indonesia have been
described by experts as similar both
planes plunging towards the earth
shortly after takeoff investigators said
the lion air pilots battled in vain to
override something called the M caste
system which was fed faulty data and
repeatedly pushed the nose of the
aircraft down Boeing says it's new fixes
make MKS less powerful and less prone to
error
they've also proposed extra training for
pilots many of whom are still furious
that Boeing didn't tell them about M
Cass before they launched the max planes
we believe that this was a serious
breach of trust between the pilot group
and the manufacturer we do feel that we
absolutely should have been made aware
of the existence of the system
absolutely should have been aware of the
way it could potentially malfunction it
was inexcusable and it absolutely should
not have happened the world's largest
commercial plane manufacturer has a lot
of work to do
Boeing may still be building its Mac's
planes but it cannot say when those
planes are going to be back in service
that is up to regulators across the
world who need to recertify the plane as
safe that might be complicated with US
politicians accusing the Federal
Aviation Authority of giving Boeing too
much freedom to approve its own designs
the fact is that the FAA decided to do
safety on the cheap which is neither
nor safe and put the Fox in charge the
henhouse with reputations faith in
flying and a lot of cash on the line
these questions will keep on coming
Hannah Thomas Peter Sky News in Renton
Washington State